we can't do a week without porn there is
a man from Tennessee he's a lawyer
actually and he's suing Apple because he
says its products are causing him to be
unable to have sex with his wife because
of all the porn and his wife is no
longer 21 and he's seeing all these hot
young chicks on the porn on his Apple
devices so he's suing Apple which
actually seems completely insane to me
he argues that they should come with a
safe mode so that he isn't constantly
tempted to watch porn because you know
if you have it on your phone and then on
your iPad and then on your MacBook it's
it's just always there and it's coming
for you is this the most ridiculous
thing you have ever heard it makes
perfect sense it makes 100% sense
absolutely you should sue Apple you
should sue everybody who everybody sue
the world just started handing out
lawsuits by the way he's John Grisham
all over this guy from Tennessee aren't
all Grisham novels a lawyer from
Tennessee yeah yeah well we know how
those end up Tom Cruise running okay so
I would sue Tom Cruise no I think this
is a I think most Americans probably
live their lives like this where they
sue Snickers because it didn't really
satisfy you know give them diabetes yeah
so you should yeah I'm gonna sue those
people where the woman's having an
orgasm in the shower cuz she's washing
her hair because I have tried over and
over I've used the bottle the right way
nothing thank you but no orgasm or goes
sue I checked my wife's head I can't
find her [ __ ] anywhere thank you but I'm
suing I'm I've been diagnosed I'm a
chronic masturbator and I'm suing
Astroglide for making my dick too
irresistible when it's all glistened up
like that right so I can't keep my hands
off myself and that's not my fault no
it's
I'm suing my parents I'm suing my
parents for making release don't don't
grab him right now because it's alright
I could go on talk about your disease
where did you catch it
I caught it a lot I caught it at a
bathhouse out of goo and that's why you
got to be careful you got to be careful
you know and you never know when you're
gonna catch that yeah
but does any suing the wrong people
that's the point it's like you're suing
Apple that's just the device okay so the
guy who makes the door on the strip club
okay I don't let me go in sex with my
wife so is their shitty sue the porn
companies then is there any legitimacy
to this any because we look there is a
ton of porn access we can all get it at
all times and is there any three of us
sue him for having to talk about yeah
yeah that's a more plausible lawsuit
that's just a guy who doesn't have the
balls to admit to his wife you know like
yeah I'm over you and I'm he presents
because of the porn honey okay so he's
no prize either
yeah I'm sure you know what I mean yeah
these guys that check out porn they're
about three thousand pounds overweight
not that I'm saying not sexy if you're
fat but I'm just saying they're usually
not like best of health not a great
purse maybe you don't charisma I'm not
saying everybody looking for that is
that no but when you start to when you
start to say I'm mad cuz my wife does it
look like this right usually you're not
prince charming yourself yeah you say
I'm saying like these guys for example
I'm you know chick on the road female
comic and these guys come to the shows
in no offense scratch your ass Arkansas
but let's just say that's where I was
performing yeah and they're like with
their you know wives who they look like
the same person practically and they're
complaining that like I want to get
someone a little younger a little Fred
hey give me some what take care of
yourself first
who are you yeah to say your wife isn't
doing it for you you're not doing it for
anybody right so let's look at yourself
first that was kind of
like man in the mirror yeah you're
saying to those guys when you point the
finger you have three fingers pointing
back at you exactly what I say is that I
also have my thumb kind of pointing at
you which is worth good thing of sorts
yeah I'm pointing because you're crying
yeah but I got nipples and I got I got
three nipples so when you do that at
work what I do there really works for me
take a look at yourself first yeah
control yourself you to Jesus I'm suing
you Astrid like yeah do you think
there's any any truth to that this poor
all this endless porn that it might be
doing something something like let me
just say this about poor yeah I knew
there was I started taking propecia like
about eight months maybe a year ago now
and so I started taking it and they say
it was lowers your libido and I was like
I could use a little lowering yeah yeah
and get some [ __ ] done finally right and
because you know I used to say I used to
be able to do any what doesn't matter
but my point is so then I did notice a
decreased libido to the point I was like
well I haven't even looked at porn for
the last two weeks I was like some and
that made me like whoa and that's why I
went off it so I'm awesome now and my
and my libido did come back cuz it did
scare me like oh my god what am I
getting his hair for if I'm not even my
even being any right because you only
want to masturbate with a full head of
hair that is the point but it's bad I
went off the booty gasm and the sex
drive came right back I mean it came
back almost double I'm so horny now they
want to [ __ ] my wife anyway I'm telling
you that is weird I know weird well I
think we should limit porn to one hour a
day yeah I can break it up in there like
four minute segments straight 11 to 12
everyone porn time that's when we get
our porn when we get our news or
whatever you know you know and that's it
I think you're on to something here
maybe in the future everything's gonna
be done in little time increments I know
to me like now with Twitter we can only
type in under forty calories in the
future you'll have a half hour for forum
half hour for the new like everything
will be broken
France
[Music]